let me ask you this when you go to
Motown and it doesn't pan out and you
have all these records can you take them
with you yeah because they're getting
people okay
they didn't do nothing like you know
what I'm saying like I never had to turn
them in because we never got there it's
crazy because Motown I feel like
mishandled like Icewear Vezzo so crazy
and now he's with well he's way back
that was my first artist to Motown yeah
oh really yeah yeah but that's dope to
see I don't know what his QC deal is
like but qc's over there in the same
building yeah so it's gonna be funny
that like now you're working with the
same people but I think they got to run
it back again yeah he did again Vezzo I
was like some people I feel like a major
label
holds him back yeah so like with this
like when I first went to Motown I was
like okay y'all Detroit label I mean
it's still Motown from Detroit I'm like
y'all ain't well you ain't got no
rappers you know being Oakland in
Detroit like I know they cracking yeah
Detroit's huge in the back and um they
kind of wasn't familiar I'm like Vezzo
was just coming home which is like the
best promo you could ever have Bros
coming home from jail unfortunately but
um I actually Ethiopia was like go get
them you know what I'm saying I'm like
yo they about to go up this would be for
Doug you know what I'm saying I think
right at that moment it's like 20 18 19
18. yeah yep so he came home from jail
signed him out the halfway house
um it was an experience for both of them
my first label his first time being on
the major so I think we were just still
trying to figure it all out together and
um you know a little couple restraints
but
when he went off on his own he wouldn't
got cracking him and he went up yeah
yeah they I think it's dope though when
he when he called me about it and he
asked me my opinion I said well you know
the Personnel yeah like man they already
know to manage it yeah you already kind
of know the deal over there so yeah so
now you got the Insight on how you
should move but uh now Ethiopia support
our artist though so cute man I got QC
uh co-signer yeah no he's hard
him and Kodak [ __ ] crazy too super crazy
100 percent